[Music]
[Applause]
overall three total
have to reestablish stop
we have the hiccup that was team
[Music]
what's up guys we're here in Berlin at
the starladder major behind me a bunch
of ants fans are commiserating after
their unfortunate loss to renegades but
hey let's focus on the positives here
we've got tons of amazing highlights
from this tournament including aces
clutches back worthy plays and more so
let's waste no more time and get into it
put into play up on that high ground
gonna be taking down Ethan
sure but the bomb is still planted and
currently nope it has been picked up
they need to find a way to get these
kills and get on that ball very quickly
and now it's all perfect person just
push through that and look at Christine
one clip of his m4 and four full as
surely here here Daisy
wrong side of the map 30 seconds of any
for buses Jax has to do something quite
special this pointy comes into the low
round finds what no problem at all ever
he can't defuse at this point it looks
like an absolute far gone he will
certainly give it over rocks should be
how to find him no problem
I say hunted up for seconds he's
ignoring him the calls are being made
spray before the deagle continues
one sandwich down and I have no issues
here Carrigan just holds it down holds
the line and the cherry on top with the
pistol and leaves kidding alone with
bomb eight seconds this time I finds the
first of the OP oh my god I found the
second as well will they be able to
trade my will they look for this Jame
goes through a white peak with a pistol
that's beautiful keeping Jayma chance
1vs1 he knows exactly where to he is
around the pillar Oh collects it i loove
it's been thrown close that might
actually help him out a little bit just
because otherwise you would have to
shoot through the smoke to try and guess
it where the bomb has been defused
there's one killing rvk and now he's
just hiding inside a loo with a quad
kill looking to get the ACE to win this
round he's gonna come right down okay
what a beautiful round here that's a
horrible angle and it will be Kerrigan
now defender Bobby the second he knows
exactly where my kids
now he can just dance around this box
play for the info I manic every step you
make every step
around and look at this it's a core just
dance back and forth he goes he's
running the clock down I mean it does
eventually overcome the odds he hasn't
got it no kid oh no worries Kerrigan's
played it to perfection what a hero play
for him abused them those numbers
towards a pea bomb sight but the one
thing ones will still prevail for level
with the 3k of walk a lower looking for
the ACE he's got two bullets left
holding down at the bomb site for his
team this could have just crushed the
dreams of complexity candy maker
yes he can decree he's gonna be inspir
some trouble hey can you get this
looking for maybe a continuation spray
falling back man just has a beautiful
cover Oh God
it looked like it could have been really
bad for D free verb magic has him
covered iPhone jakey I see to put sauce
the greatest faction will be pushed down
in the corner trying to survive for as
long as he can but they don't know where
Jake es is maybe just maybe enough time
was poor and holding the VP's Lego JK s
he picks it up they're gonna separate
from that ball top James still wants to
fight there's the jump back huge shot
mob hits the deck and vitality is gonna
have to scramble to recover and Jame
coming back now has a chance on a hate
back City Scott that as well
four kills in the round for Jamie and
disaster strikes vitality so hungry is
gonna eat the entire team run your beat
it's a classic
kick it never stood a chance
close you win the fight he's out in the
open chest out fighting every single one
and somehow he comes out way on top side
whenever trying to fight his way back
and he's gonna have to get the ACE to
try and shut this round down and bring
his team maybe finally back into the
game a little bit he's got the right
idea but ad rent again is such a smart
player
he's been playing whatever and he's
sneaking up behind side hood still can't
get the kill and now tangi ready and
waiting side wall he's just tapping away
at the door he wants the fight is he
gonna be able to get it still alive and
only a56 help that's not a lot against
that USP he fakes the bomb a single time
and he's
[Applause]
headshots dinosaur doing what he can
with his mp9 they're jumping accuracy is
very good and we play me download maybe
there's a chance for a big swing we
stand can he find it with this MP and I
trying to tease out the perfect puppet
by someone this is why
and now it's down to tyrant against
three has to find a way that feel is
simple but they all walk the way in the
market position tarik if you can make a
forward play head maybe that's it takes
down electronic quick flash back through
the window trying to get some
information try together and then
another player town and he knows that
actually he's pushed and all the way
back in market he's created so much
space for himself in this one versus two
unbelievable effort from Tariq already
the area he's just forced away from the
CTS is ridiculous now where is he does
the question we see a rotation from
simple creeping on shore but he missed
his stop 1v1 hasn't never flame is but
you may soon find out the score is time
and now the panic sets in for liquid
have top recipients dead now
it's a 2-1 to Australia stand their
ground on the B bomb site and it's a
legion with six help I can't believe the
recurrence sip with the triple and a
lead alone in a one versus two we take
[Applause]
Jes is finding his way forward edging
closer and closer to try to make this
clutter reality as Jame and Sanji make
this painful they're trying to go for
the double peak with the time used on
perfect he could go deep to allow the
CTE guys to make a play you can see him
there's a huge raise and they're making
a good go of this xoans court often long
but I don't think he's the one that's
caught off they're locked in here with
him and that's you from sigh whoo do not
cut along keep int Z out of the a bond
site for a little bit they try and go
through this smoke and that is to their
demise because Gabe is shutting me down
to find another and now walk sick the
only man left inside of the ball
although a buddy drop the bomb 35
seconds left and he's buying so much
time for these rotations Jerry is closed
but walk sick third kill he's continuing
to put up numbers multiple together big
stuff from gate the fact that he gets to
third as well like he's just done that
rushing with the pistols now but Alexi
be in a position to succeed head shots
for days as he looks to finish off this
round and it looks pretty damn good now
watch this year they can put a slope
down at the base of the entrance if
they'd like to soos all alone on the
speed bomb so but they can line up quick
easy con electrode they do Zeus's got
amaz on high alert as you will they're
here they're running there's the first
challenge beautiful from Sergei
absolutely fantastic and he gets another
one out of it we wish to Orton presence
in a bit position but not to you've
rotated
towards that timing is absolutely
perfect isn't it yeah that's a great way
to start and maybe that kids mcclure saw
was happening for Hobby players rotate
in flame you say flows behind evil buoys
picks up another one now NRT are in
trouble who is absolutely decimating
absolutely everyone what a play from him
you want the information it's perfectly
timed it's so perfectly time alesia's in
the corner to freeze a little bit lucky
but it's even better shot ooh looking to
go for the peak credits factions ready
for that goes back out that house a
close one all nice follow-up from gratis
packs and punishes LXE B who went for
the trade kill Grannis fashion shots to
- Jes tries to the fed towards the a
rapper more space will be claimed by
again
gratis Paxson turns up mangas rip down
with the blankness he's gonna find the
bomb as well let's see we could get the
kill nobody's currently looking behind
Knapp is also gone down this could be an
disaster for liquid it looks like it
will be biggest chewing them up
[Applause]
we're moving into a split of the B
bauxite and simples in position three
practice use great angle for simple
needs one more and the gains are four
grounds away from being in the grand
finals may just take him down Stanislaw
it's only globs on the other side now
double peep somehow winning the fight
against device is very awkward fight for
a minute like that whatsoever matches
what's all of it though he wants to
battle he's gonna get the first
ridiculous bread and even Turkey yeah
that mapped out in his brain in need
just such a seamless sequence and he's
gonna get the ACE he wants all five
kills he wants his shot at glory guys
aces and clutches are one thing but
sometimes you see a highlight that makes
you think can he even [ __ ] do that
this next section is all about the back
worthy plays from the Berlin major
crunch now it costs going on top of the
hub okay dick Stacey what three kills
the ball oh my lord it's Stacey that is
not allowed a month for like pinching
off long range three click three forever
net will be up to box ik with his p2000
to take down a Zeke and you can hear
what that means - Emma oh my goodness
see that enhancer nothing valuable to
lose there's the first there's the
second a nice snap overhaul that's even
more beautiful on the honey what's the
fight apex in transition gorgeous
connection
another frag for Dexter he has been the
shining light for greyhound gaming he's
got no yes on earth pulling dream eaters
kicking and screaming positive situation
take me thank you that's what I kept
that's gorgeous of course it's kinky in
Berlin this is a disaster James gonna go
down here
once again other guards traps they have
nowhere to go
they must kill the Vice double flash
most of the smoke right around the edge
he knows the aks the tracers there's the
option and he's got another angle now
into the bombsite engine my sister's
raining down death what a problem with
restricting where of a guarded play and
they're all gonna forget with the
seagull four killers second case might
be check the garbage out here comes
energy once again been set close with
the AEK gets himself a quick triple that
is fantastic the pumps down on the
ground as breeze now has to make quick
work as he moves towards oh why they put
cancer keys absolute God what the hell
chase summer attacks and Jax has to work
back out for fame the default ball and a
third through the smoke water job from
here there we go
please in the notes yes there it is
beautiful this is the slow motion there
it is you'd love to see that perfect as
he emerges out of that smoke Christina
just wing is over the stove because he's
got friction burns on his wrists from
that one look at this in slow mode yeah
all frozen okay and it's actually gonna
pull away players device here's the
running kinky us a great shot and that
is so needed as well oh my goodness fee
that comes back in as well kinky long
range my god what is this dream eaters
and dilating this push who which coming
up with the mp9 long-range spray to take
down hunter that is a lot reduction Oh
Esperanto he wanted more are now simple
or perhaps they're looking to see him
that you would give them something give
them an argument to really commit to
this bomb site take the carrot goes once
flashback but a double will certainly
steal the deal has to now be have to get
out of there
but Eric
[Applause]
well guys so far we've seen some
incredible moments in the server but and
a major sometimes it's the stuff that
happens out of game that we remember the
most here are the most incredible out of
game moments from Berlin it looks good
it looks good but they have to confirm
it our casters get another just sigh
whoo no hope surely just the tickets
confined we're going into three hahaha
spectacular to furnish into a back win
it's it's certainly been up and down but
for now it is only down for it easy they
have a chance to you know come back in
the future and hopefully we'll be able
to solve some of their problems but not
everyone can win here at the major area
is cutthroat you can see how much this
means to the matter started major
[Applause]
on three months
absolutely
amazing performance okay James just
shrunk as if it was just two weeks he's
like surprised it was that easy
no one celebrating until they even
finish the defuse like [ __ ] hopeless
like they don't even know how to win yet
back-to-back legends back at the top
eight but unfortunately for ends and for
Alexi be the road ends here Alexi be it
goes without being said that despite the
extremely difficult circumstances in
which you have to play at this major
today and throughout this major you have
played your heart out on the server
what's going through your head right now
nothing actually I'm just glad I'm here
and all the fans giving giving me
support and my family being here too you
have created so many fans over this past
year even if this is the last time that
we get to see you wear this jersey you
have gained fans for the rest of your
career who will be supporting you any
final words for them just thanks to
everyone everyone here thank you
[Music]
having gone on the cat's up on the road
back to round stands in a moment guys on
loud enough where support for these guys
it wants to rip the ones that really
games mostly made their own I respect
that yeah you know you've often
predicted against the renegade this
event you felt like they could do it
there was like I got one thing to say I
like I only have one thing to say
security what is this this liquid inside
the chute what is coming next
what's coming next this is outrageous
with them I guess we'll have to operate
with a three-man desk well guys that is
it for the best of the Berlin major we
saw some incredible highlights and some
unforgettable moments and now that the
video is over I think you know what to
do
[Music]
exactly
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]